idris devi presented himself as a strong
leader
and that's what he was for his allies in
the west and
in africa this was him on the
battlefront near a lecture
last year when his troops fought and
eventually expelled boko haram
in an isil-affiliated group
his death on another battlefront is a
huge blow to allies and the fight
against armed groups in the sahel
and elsewhere in africa there are
concerns that with security challenges
increasing at whom
the country may limit or even reduce its
participation
in external conflicts it was reported
two or three days ago
that debbie before he died was moving
units that he had deployed to mali and
niger back to chad to help defend the
capital
these are some of his best units so if
the current
interim government has to keep those
units in chad for security purposes
um then that would disrupt at least in
the short term france's and the broader
g5s
counter-terrorism efforts in in mali and
niger
and those rebels remain a threat a
further deterioration of security in
charge could trigger the withdrawal of
its troops from regional hotspots
to bolster security at home this will in
turn leave many countries in the sahel
and lakeshore regions
more vulnerable since charging troops
there play a significant role
in stopping armed groups from
overrunning many communities
chad a country with a history of course
civil war and tribal conflicts
is battling various rebel groups the
latest being the one in which president
debbie
lost his life the group was until a year
ago based in libya
and was fighting alongside mercenaries
and the khalifa
ironically uh one of the reasons that
they're coming back into chad right now
is because of the peace agreement
that was forged under the united nations
auspices
in libya requiring all foreign armies uh
to to leave the country and so they're
doing just that they're bringing with
them
the training and the arms uh that they
gained
inside of libya and they're bringing
them to chad
with the region awash with heavy and
small weapons from the libya conflict
experts say child and the entire region
could see an uptick in violence by
rebels
and armed groups in coming months
western powers consider debbie as a
dependable ally
and would want chadian forces to
continue to play that role
whether the new military government
having so much to deal with right now
there are no guarantees
that chadian troops will continue to
fight others battles while there is
trouble
at home muhammad idris al jazeera abuja